so in this case with johnny and amber
johnny filed for divorce and johnny is
the one that's like listen
here's what happened she's dropping my
name out there and the fame and
everybody's thinking i'm a bad guy i'm
not a bad guy and then you get all these
other guys that are coming and say look
i've done cocaine i probably did you do
drugs with that person yes did you do a
drug with this person yes why did you do
drugs with that person i'm not gonna lie
to you i just wanted him to shut up
because he was talking too much like i
don't know who he was talking about
manson or one of those guys right
but he's just talking straight up right
you're going through this there's a part
of this that
you have to be
very very careful there are people out
there relationship wise that if you're
in a bad relationship
it's realistic that you can
you can have your career being hurt if
you date the wrong person you have to be
so careful in hollywood you know who
you're married you have to be so careful
in sports who your all of this stuff